[Music]
so basically from the video that you can
see the mums I turned off because the
mom came and the moms kind of cried but
he's had a knife the other knife he had
a knife in his hand
yeah so it's Winona and you know the
amount of people that are dying because
of knife crime now obviously as far as I
don't I see in the other night yeah I'm
not saying if you did or he didn't I
don't know but you know it just shows
you look as moms crying its final you
know it's it's sad all night son
[Music]
[Music]
it's not what a Kawada metal a better
care two brothers and sisters and dear
friends this happened while we was
walking we came back from meeting were
just walking down the road and we saw
some commotion and we headed towards
where it was happening and this is what
we saw them there was a lot of things
happening there's a lot commotion the
saddest part of it all was obviously
well the shocking part of this of it all
was that we know in the UK that knife
crime is increasing crazy an epidemic
level and to see a man on the floor and
the knife there it was quite you know
shocking to see it's like okay this is
and this is coming to our doors now Judy
I'm trying to say
and obviously that was again kind of a
kind of experience but then to see like
as I was recording you see a lady
walking past and we didn't even know and
she walked past and turned around and
saw her own son and started screaming
you know and then a grown man who's
involved in gangs you know most likely
involve guns if he's carrying a knife
you know maybe I'm assuming that to
start crying like a baby yeah and it
shows you the reality of this lifestyle
yeah now there's a lot lesson that we
can learn from this so for example the
mum imagine the mom is crying and
shouting because she knows that sounds
gonna go to journal he's done something
wrong she's upset nobody wants to see
their child like that
they're from the other angle it's the
fact that this guy is carrying that
knife
imagine if he killed and stuff somebody
like the youngsters are dying every day
imagine this my mother
well you can say thank God in a way
didn't see their son stabbed to death I
saw their son potentially could have
some stop someone to that what my end up
in jail she was upset and that was
heartbreaking for us all you know that's
what I was taught to in holding but
imagine now all the family members who
was who have seen or heard or had a
phone call then your loved one was
stabbed to death and they died yeah and
that man over there on the floor it's
really maybe one of those people that
are responsible for these attacks are
happening and we need to learn a lesson
from his more brothers and sisters and
understand that look this life is
Indonesian yeah this unit on Santa
Stuyvesant delusion and chasing the
slash is not gonna be nothing these
people who are pushing this lifestyle be
accountants gangs girls all this kind of
stuff they are they
about this life they just chat they just
know of these rappers that you talk
about the dude talk about gun guns and
this that they get caught in the court
on the road and they get robbed yeah
they get rotten this stock right now
allow me an army yeah there's a lot of
this son because they're not about this
life it's all freak yeah so don't get
caught up in the madness the crazy stuff
that's happening look I had my jaw here
yeah I I was involved in certain guns
and stuff like that
you had an inventory something you think
you're a gang member whether you aren't
till somebody puts a gun to your face or
a knife you start right the biggest man
you saw please allow me allow me here
okay one bullet and you finished no
matter how big you are how hint you are
what kind of bulletproof vest you have
not from one bullet to your head your
gun one knife to a fight to organ you're
finished yeah you're finished and it
just doesn't end there
they got it you would wish they'd ends
there okay I'm dead undone no it doesn't
end there buffer that's not the
beginning yeah now you going to answer
you're not you're gonna answer to your
other ones gonna ask you I've given you
this wealth of unity the health I've
given you this this and this what did
you do with it Allah did nothing I was
fighting I thought I owned the area
called n 15 and 19 and W this and W that
and I was fighting for this territory oh
did I own the territory no or I just
deluded myself and believe that this is
my ends nobody can come by to my hands
I'm gonna prove my point after prove a
point so I'm gonna come and stab you and
do this and kill you over property that
I don't own yeah this how crazy and wild
it's become I knew destroying lives
you're not just killing you only the
person innocently yeah the process of a
lot of seldom said one of the signs of
the hour is that the person who's dying
doesn't know why it's time the person
who's killing doesn't know why it's
killing yeah so we need to understand
that when you're killing somebody it's
not just that person has died you're
killing their family members every day
they're dying every day they're going to
die every day yeah you wouldn't want
that for your family members yeah so
brothers and sisters please come to your
senses well I you're just deluding
yourself fix up a knee i I had to count
realization worse end of the song
monsters the people believe me I I have
my journey where I'm going to fight for
everybody help them this time what like
once once this is look I'm telling you
I've never said share this in my life
first I was showing it I got jumped once
all the people that I helped what I
don't them can't tell me oh that was a
boy I was there for you I was definitely
none of them kid help me so it's these
realizations you know you have to be
clever be clever
learn from other people's mistakes leave
this lifestyle leave it and another
thing is the rights of your parents your
mum a man came across a settlement said
who has more rights over me he said your
mother and then he said your mother and
then a movie said your mother and then
you sit in your father yeah your parents
have rights over you yeah and your mum
when you put your mum through that
torture well lie you're gonna be
punished unless there's no fraud after I
ask you to worship me obey your parents
be good to your parents up to live it
uma saw a man writing about and he saw a
man carrying his mum doing Tawaf around
the cabin and as he was doing that he
was humiliating sir who said I had my
mother's humble camo I'm a mother's
humble camel yeah often he did the Toa
he came tough but I've been honest he
said have I paid back my mum for what
she's done for me he said you did not
pay her back for one roof she said when
she gave birth to you and look at this
child what is for his parents for his
mom look at her mom is his mum crying
out loud well I shall tell you something
one of the companies when they mutt when
his mother died he was crying so much he
said one of my doors too generous but
one of my daughter generates good what
why you never get another mama you never
ever ever get another mom believe me
believe me believe me one line is a
reminder to myself first
your daughter Jenna your success in this
life obedience to your parents your
mother specific and your father of
course your mother your mother what why
I'm telling you kiss her feet I'm
telling you kiss her feet whenever she
says to you we are told not to even say
off to our mother off yeah
and it's a reminder to me I'm not become
an angel there's no things I need to
work on but my mother I tried my best
while I before I leave the door I was
saying mom please make dua for me if
there's a little thing five minutes I've
upset my mom a little bit
well I have less scared of leaving the
store I don't know if allowance in the
calamity my said mom please forgive me
if I've upset you in any way directly
indirectly forgive me and I asked
because what my I know my mother's dois
Imam Bihari he was a blind man he was
blind his mom made his mum's constant to
us yeah even there is a real-life story
of a man who's who's an imam of the
harem yeah and he told the story where
his mom would make du'a and say every
time look how beautiful the curtains
every time she was angry usually moms
curse yeah and what I see dangerous
scares me you know if you got it if my
mum and before back in the days have
nice to be naughty etc you had it today
figured about your life my mom was too
close to me how well that I would I
would think anytime Allah I don't know
what would happen
yeah I'm denying it she doesn't me I
bless us mixed well but the issue is
that this mother would always say may
Allah make you the imam of the Kappa
Kappa and this is what he would always
she would always see and this man ended
up being the Imam of the cabin it's a
real story real stories on YouTube you
can watch it be obedient this is your
success and were lying the biggest
destruction
anybody what I have had witnesses I have
seen people who swell up their mother
who hit their mother yeah
why you not the most vile animals I have
not seen one like I've not seen success
in them they have become lost
corrupted sauce lost corrupted sauce so
brothers and sisters obey your parents
and shut tell you something
obedience what is that I don't you were
gonna say my mother has passed away how
am I gonna do obedience we are told the
phosphorus atom has told us I found a
mistaken
obedience to your parents even if they
are passed away is what that one of them
is that you do good to their friends you
visit their friends often this is number
one number one number two is that you
made to offer them that's the form of
obedience did you understand that even
if they have passed away you
you can be obedient to them by praying
for them that's the form of obedience
may fall for them when you pray for
budget except me - up man everything
I'll make 2 hour long time my father -
stop guy open his heart it's tough make
my mom come closer to Islam pray etc my
brother my family members that is you
need that my there right up on me yeah
and I do that in sha Allah and I ask
because they do the same and let's not
have these scenes I mean asked this
brother he was been arrested he changes
laughs around he repents he comes closer
to God and he makes his happy the
pleasure of Allah inshallah is at the
pleasure of the parents that's what he
says after you obey me obey your mom
yeah and the one whose disobedience to
his Lord of course would not care about
his parents it's a little minor for me
my dear brothers and sisters may our
best you guys for watching I hope you
guys have benefited if I missed out
anything to diminish or if I've said
anything wrong from Shaytan to myself
and everything good is from allah
subhanho wa taala may allah bless you
guys to make some shadows subscribe
share this video and shala if anybody
else wants and to access this video in
the media channels etc get in contact me
inshallah I do not mind you can share it
as long as you just put a link and in
sha Allah people and it give awareness
so people can watch the talent show from
what we do so next time strong belief or
what I better catch you've got more
videos coming subscribe take care